si tiene hiperlipidemia comúnmente
conocido como colesterol alto usted
tiene altos niveles de lípidos en su
sangre los lípidos son grasas y
sustancias parecidas a las grasas en
esta condición los tipos más comunes de
lípidos son el colesterol y los
triglicéridos
su cuerpo necesita colesterol para
funcionar de forma apropiada produce
todo el colesterol que necesita
mayormente en su hígado
y las células en su cuerpo necesitan
colesterol como parte de su membrana
celular
su piel utiliza la luz solar y el
colesterol para producir la vitamina d
ciertas glándulas como los testículos en
el hombre y glándulas suprarrenales
utilizan el colesterol para producir
químicos importantes llamados hormonas
además su hígado utiliza colesterol para
producir ácidos biliares que ayudan a
digerir grasas en los alimentos que come
su cuerpo utiliza triglicéridos para
producir energía los triglicéridos en su
sangre provienen de los alimentos y de
su hígado los alimentos altos en
triglicéridos incluyen comidas grasosas
carbohidratos refinados alimentos con
altos contenidos de azúcares simples y
alcohol
y los lípidos no pueden desplazarse
desde su hígado a través del flujo
sanguíneo sin algunos ajustes para
habilitar su desplazamiento su hígado
almacena ciertas proteínas alrededor de
los lípidos la nueva molécula resultante
llamada lipoproteína puede desplazarse a
través del flujo sanguíneo a través de
su cuerpo hacia las células que la
necesitan dependiendo del tipo de
lipoproteína su colesterol forma parte
de lo que determina si su colesterol es
bueno o malo por ejemplo su hígado
produce lipoproteínas de muy baja
densidad o ldl que son la fuente del
colesterol malo o ldl estas
lipoproteínas están llenas de colesterol
y triglicéridos
las bl dl viajan a través de su flujo
sanguíneo llevando los triglicéridos a
sus células que los utilizan para
producir energía
si su hígado produce más vélez de él de
lo que su cuerpo necesita para producir
energía
labbé ldl almacena los triglicéridos
extras como grasa corporal
después de perder sus triglicéridos una
bl dl se vuelve una lipoproteína de baja
densidad o ldl y la l dl viaja a través
de su flujo sanguíneo llevando el
colesterol a las células que lo
necesitan si su cuerpo produce
demasiadas ldl éstas se pueden acumular
en su sangre la l dl se puede depositar
en las paredes en sus vasos sanguíneos
provocando una acumulación de materia
grasa llamada placa un daño en los vasos
sanguíneos pueden facilitar que la el dl
forme placas con el tiempo esta
acumulación puede reducir el vaso
sanguíneo y reducir el flujo sanguíneo
este es el motivo por el cual la ldl el
llamado colesterol malo un lugar común
en donde se puede acumular esta placa es
en sus arterias coronarias que son los
vasos sanguíneos que alimentan su
músculo cardíaco esta acumulación
provoca cardiopatía coronaria e
incrementa el riesgo a sufrir un ataque
cardíaco la placa en otras arterias como
las arterias carótidas en su cuello
pueden reducir el flujo sanguíneo hacia
su cerebro e incrementan el riesgo de un
accidente cerebrovascular
su hígado también produce lipoproteínas
de alta densidad hdl también conocidas
como colesterol bueno hdl tiene más
proteínas y muy poco colesterol y
triglicéridos en comparación con la l dl
la hdl ayuda a remover el exceso de
colesterol de sus células
y de la placa en sus vasos sanguíneos
este es el motivo por el cual la hdl es
llamada colesterol bueno hdl devuelve el
exceso de colesterol a su hígado el cual
lo elimina de su cuerpo
si tiene 20 años de edad o más national
institutes of health recomienda hacerse
una prueba de sangre cada 5 años llamada
perfil de lipoproteína en ayunas mide
sus niveles de colesterol total ldl
hdl
y triglicéridos
durante esta evaluación se le tomará una
muestra de sangre de su brazo o dedo
después que no haya comido entre 9 a 12
horas
el objetivo del colesterol total debe
ser menor a 200 miligramos por decilitro
para la mayoría de personas una hdl
ideal o colesterol bueno debe ser 60 o
mayor una l dl ideal o colesterol malo
debe ser menor a 100
y los triglicéridos en ayunas deben ser
menores a 150 su objetivo específico
puede variar dependiendo en la situación
de su salud pregúntele a su médico
cuáles deben ser los objetivos de los
lípidos
si sus niveles de colesterol son muy
altos es importante comer una dieta
saludable para el corazón con fuentes
magras de proteínas y rica en frutas y
vegetales
también los tipos de grasas que usted
come pueden afectar su nivel de
colesterol
por ejemplo grasas saturadas y grasas
trans tienden a elevar el colesterol ldl
en su sangre
estas grasas usualmente son sólidas a
temperatura ambiente y se encuentran en
la carne y en los productos lácteos
muchos alimentos procesados y aceites
tropicales como el aceite de palma y la
manteca de cacao
y las grasas no saturadas incluyendo
grasas poliinsaturadas y monoinsaturadas
son grasas más sanas de lo que
usualmente son más líquidos a
temperatura ambiente ellos se encuentran
en los alimentos como pescado nueces y
aceites vegetales
otra de las decisiones que puede tomar
en su estilo de vida para ayudar a su
colesterol es no fumar
y ejercitarse regularmente como caminar
a paso ligero o correr
si los cambios en su estilo de vida no
pueden reducir lo suficiente sus niveles
de colesterol su médico puede
resultarles ciertos medicamentos para
reducirlo las estatinas son medicamentos
que reducen la cantidad de colesterol
que se produce en su hígado estos
afectan los niveles de ldl más que la
hdl o los niveles de triglicéridos la
niacina reduce el colesterol ldl y los
triglicéridos e incrementa el colesterol
hdl producido en su hígado
y las resinas de ácido biliar son
medicamentos que evitan el reuso de
bilis después de ayudar a digerir su
alimento como resultado su hígado
utiliza más colesterol para reemplazar
la bilis perdida lo que significa menos
colesterol en el flujo sanguíneo
los fibratos son principalmente
utilizados para reducir los niveles de
triglicéridos en su sangre pero también
pueden elevar sus niveles de hdl
los inhibidores de absorción de
colesterol reducen la cantidad de
colesterol absorbido por sus intestinos
de los alimentos que consume
en muchos casos los mismos pasos pueden
ayudar a mantener niveles de colesterol
y triglicéridos saludables cómo comer
una dieta baja en grasas saturadas
grasas trans y colesterol
ejercitarse regularmente
y controlar su peso
y dejar de fumar